what up what up fellas your boy ryan
from las vegas
just want to start off by saying i'm a
huge fan of the show uh
and i got a debate club for you or it
could be a king interesting at either
one
but i just binge listened to every
single episode of king and the sting and
by the way it was super cool to see you
guys evolve
and see you guys transform from episode
one to now but with binge listening i
noticed
i think it was episode 62 you guys when
tom brady was talking about
leaving the patriots right you guys
joked around and said that i think there
was talks about him going to the
chargers but you guys joked around and
said tom brady was gonna leave
and then i think it was brendan made a
joke about gronkowski going
and then antonio brown going and then
they're making it to the super bowl well
look
it's happened they're all there all
three of them went there and now they're
all going to the super bowl so what do
you guys think what are your thoughts on
on tom brady making to another super
bowl do you think they can pull it off
uh let me know what you guys think i
would love to hear your uh hear your
opinions
thanks a lot guys gang gang buzz buzz
thanks for powering through all the
episodes my man
wow therapist after that
uh i i want to see tom brady win
i'm rooting for tom brady i mean
obviously the cool things to do is patch
my homes and the chiefs
everybody's on their nuts but i'm
looking for that old gunslinger
yeah i'm brady man antonio brown gets a
[ __ ] trophy that'd be dope
antonio brown seems like a real [ __ ] but
uh i think
it would be i think it could be really
you know there's something that's only
three
oh no i think look they definitely want
to get a lot of people to bet on tampa
bay
i mean i think there's a good chance
that kansas city could win by 12 points
you know they could blow him out yeah i
mean i think tom brady could get out
there and lose it in the last drive it
seems like it could be that kind of game
i'm trying to think about you can't go
double or nothing with that with you you
gotta
say that i'm pretty happy with my money
and i already donated to the damn
[ __ ]
[ __ ] thing you know sorry i'm just angry
that
i keep [ __ ] donating money to this
thing
so but yeah the good fight foundation
you can find it on
dustin's website but um
yeah dude i think i think it's
interesting to be able to cheer for a
great quarterback now that he's
separated from the team that everybody
thought was like
it becomes like they thought belichick
was like the secret sauce you realize he
ain't [ __ ] but an
[ __ ] yeah well he ain't [ __ ] without
this dude but yeah it's definitely brady
do with it yeah hell yeah
everything to do with it but belichick
also he [ __ ] picked uh
cam newton you know what i'm saying like
that was just horrible they had nothing
to do
you know like they had nobody else yeah
it must have been a front off oh yeah
what are you doing for the are you doing
anything for super bowl are you going to
be in l.a you mean
i'll probably be in nashville all right
i'm super michael chandler invited me
over you are having one if i'm here i'll
come
all right i've been 40 years your bowl
party haven't i'm sure yeah every year
so but yeah look man i don't know what
what is your prediction
i'll bet the over of i think 56 so i'll
bet the
over and i'm hoping the tampa bay
buccaneers win but
it's tough man pesky my home's so
[ __ ] good
kill they're so good tyree kill is
insane
the cheetah his three legs dude someone
said his dick has an
ankle on it yeah and five toes
yeah he's a beast that's unfair
you know what i'm saying check that
dude's [ __ ] dick
somebody said he got a massage on his
dick the other day i'm sure man
that because he [ __ ] sprained it
doing a turn that's insane yeah
i'm going for tampa but it's gonna be a
tough one somebody said he had [ __ ]
turf toe in the end of his dick okay
he had to get his dick wrapped yeah he
had tinnitus in his penis i heard his
dick have cte
from bouncing around while he's running
around oh dude somebody said his dick
was in a neck brace from [ __ ]
whiplash from one of the [ __ ] orders
because a visor
[Laughter]
why i don't know yeah you're right
[Music]
is